Kelly how do you feel when somebody says
that women are Beauty objects
why does it hurt I'm definitely a
feminist like I mean but I'm not like
one of those
you know ones that want to dominate and
use the word term dominate outside the
bedroom but I'm definitely you know I
believe
you know women have gotten a bad rap for
a long time and the statistics that you
gave me earlier were sad I didn't know
them
um about the marriage lasting but I mean
very eye-opening and very
you know obviously I think two people
that want to make that commitment should
really discuss it and talk about it
before they jump into it because it
again all these let me just take you
back to the to the you know women are
Beauty objects like why does that hurt
you
um it hurts because
it's people think it's a compliment
um I've had some guys you know kind of
throw it at me or whatever and I'm like
that's not a compliment that's an ear
basic like it's yeah okay thank you for
calling me beautiful or whatever but
it's like you could have said that in a
different way than I'm an object I'm no
one's object I mean I'm or possession or
whatever like I am a living human being
just like you how does that how does
this sit with you Sam if uh you know if
I were to say that you know women are
Beauty objects
um it's so funny you ask that question
beneath that because that was one of the
moments where I was like yep I'm gonna
go on this podcast because I want to
talk about that uh but
um
to the way that you were posing it in
the original podcast I was listening to
I I understand what you're saying and to
an extent I agree I guess that's a very
cryptic way of answering that question
um I cryptically agree because then you
say in the return of that men are
success objects yeah so then I guess
what I was dying to pose is one of the
the questions I was going to pose was to
you was
if you know
if uh man if you're with if Gia and her
husband God forbid you know they've been
together for you know almost like over
20 years they're in deep and strong and
let's pretend he was the breadwinner
from the get and make in successful so
and so forth all of a sudden he loses
all of his income his life shatters like
just financially just all the success
out the window and then Gia were to
decide to leave that relationship what
is Gia called
no if she's if no because that's that's
an naive answer because the reality is
she's called a gold digger because she
was only after sorry the money correct
if the minute it goes wouldn't she be
considered a gold digger I I mean I've
never heard that but possibly by some
cruel people or guys
um but honestly if you love that person
so much you would not leave them I'm not
saying she she would be a good or not
even oh no I I yeah I'm posing the
question for the men yeah that like that
like brings you back to the distilled
sound bite of women don't care about
men's struggles they hang out the finish
line and they pick the winner right so
women don't have a long they don't have
a lot of tolerance for a guy that can't
sort it out I think they'll have
patience for setbacks failures stand by
his side uh you know depending on the
type of relationship they have and I
want to speak for GM you know I'm sure
that she could speak for herself and I
want to hear from her as well but
um generally speaking if the guy can't
get it together the clock is ticking
down to the end of that relationship at
some point especially if she has options
right like if she's attractive and she
has options out in the world and he
can't figure it out that's one of the
reasons why women will untie the knot
and leave a marriage right so in your
perspective in that circumstance should
the female if the guy just lost
everything
scratching at the cardboard box unable
to get out in that moment well she's not
digging any gold if she's leaving well
I'm leaving I mean that situation would
you say it would you be like no no you
would fully expect her to leave correct
based off of your assumption of women
yeah that's why I tell men to chase
Excellence you know to get their lives
sorted out and squared away so that
they've so they've got the financial
resources and the network and the social
influence and the captivation to keep a
woman around because women don't care
about men's struggles like they do have
a certain degree of patience but they're
but the clock ticks down to the end of
the relationship at some point if they
can't figure it out gee like you know
she's basically posing the question in
your relationship what are your thoughts
on that woman left a man because he lost
everything absolutely she's going to be
called a gold digger I agree with you on
that that's that's what typically
happens
I met my husband he was not in a good
space had really bad credit his ex
basically you know long story short he
was in a very very bad spot and I came
in cleaned up his credit you know bought
a home got him out of the the space that
he was adopted his son you know got him
back to square one so you know he could
pursue what he wanted to do
um and it's never been a matter of money
for me because I I came in very
financially you know I had my first job
at age 10 had my first house at 17. I've
been working I'm a little bit of a
workability but long story short
I think that
yes if a woman does leave a man in the
middle of a relationship after you know
he's lost everything I don't I would
consider her over gold digger because
that's why she was there there's no real
you know connection past that which is
unfortunate yeah there'd be like that
negative and I wouldn't like I would
just look at that as ah I purging me it
was better than that okay so then you
wouldn't because the question more or
less was directing towards the gentleman
here of what your interpretation of that
would be but everybody thinks like me
though Salma like I have a very
different perspective than most men I
think society and culture to some degree
would probably like see it from the
perspective of oh well she was only
there for the money or she was just a
gold digger and what fell apart but I
would just look at it from the
perspective well that's just in female
nature right you know they're not akin
to stick around if a guy can't figure it
out like she's got like women have sort
of deadlines in their heads you know
they set sort of like clocks you know
well if you can't do it by this date if
he doesn't propose to me by this date if
he can't get out of debt by this date or
if he can't dig out of this hole by a
certain period of time that I got to
figure out you know some other options
Kelly you're shaking your head left you
know why
um because I just don't I don't I don't
believe that I feel like a lot part of
it um pretty much all of it I I mean I
hate to say it sorry but
um it's just if your partner loses
everything then
I would do just like what Jesus is like
that's a mate she loved she loves this
man so much that she stepped up and she
you know took care of him and like
nurtured him and that's how I believe
like if my man loses everything and then
I'm gonna step up and do my part in
order for him to get his shirt out yes
we have time I mean sort of timelines
but
I mean well there's going to be a point
where you no longer are gonna put your
best foot forward because that guy's not
gonna figure it out or he's not gonna
try to figure it out
I can prove that virtue right now that
you're signaling right now Kelly
completely wrong and I'm not trying to
do this on the spot to make you look bad
but you left a guy that was a bum that
was drunk on the street at four o'clock
in the morning because he couldn't fix
his [__] right so to say that you know
I'll I'll just stay with him till The
Bitter End because of because of love
like that like that feeling is it's nice
to State and it's what we've been
basically hammered into our psyche and
our ego for years and years to say and
and do but the reality of behavior is
different from what we State and I think
that one of the things that I've been
known for stating over and over again to
guys is watch the behaviors and it's not
just women it's watch the behaviors of
people in general and what they do and
how they respond to certain scenarios
don't don't believe what they say go
ahead I've never sorry sorry I've never
mentioned that I left him because
he couldn't get his [__] together that
was
nice yeah I did not say that ever okay
so why'd you leave him then I left him
because
so not together it like it wasn't when I
first met him but I stuck around and
like yeah I mean there's no timeline on
it I just had enough I hit my breaking
point I thought to myself you're
literally saying that's what you were
saying
everyone reaches their breaking point
you found yours that's all we're seeing
and I just wrecked that I'm not
I know that's what I'm saying yeah
just reflecting back what I saw right I
think everyone in the world could say
there's a point of diminishing returns
of course but I think Gia is a the
literally the most beautiful example of
a contradiction to to what that sound
bite is that you say Rich where it's a
girl's always just waiting at the Finish
Line G in her example is literally the
exact contradiction but I think that
even Gia would admit that they're
talking about there would be a timeline
for her to to like you know if it took
her two or three years to fix all of
that if that ended up taking six seven
eight nine years there would have come a
point in her mind I would imagine and I
want her to speak herself obviously but
where she would have gotten to [__] this
I'm out right right yeah well am I wrong
you know
[Music]
we have to start paying attention to
what's really going on as a whole you
know and I'm I'm an exception so you
can't you can't look at what I'm you
know what I do when it's
it's too few like we have to see the
majority of women right now are not
subservient you know they think that
they are tens when they're not they
think they're owed the world they're not
and you know men you know a guy can be a
wonderful man just because he doesn't
have a six figure you know but all these
women think that they deserve six
figures what is that one percent of the
entire population you know it's just it
it's what as a map You Know Rich the
masses right now that's why marriage is
dying because women are not subservient
I think that's really what femininity is
isn't it
yeah there's a I think there's a lot of
contributing factors you know beyond
just you know subservance or and you
know subservant sounds so wrong and
hurtful to a lot of people especially
women that that are that are like
they're on that steady diet and drunk on
the Kool-Aid of uh egalitarianism and
we're equal and we're a team and all
that sort of stuff which is why I was
sort of challenging Kelly on that notion
a little bit because I mean you know I
said earlier like how do you how do you
respond to the notion that women are
Beauty objects and you're like well it
kind of hurts but here I am you know
sitting before you and you're all
dressed up you've put some thought into
your outfit you've got your makeup and
your earrings and your eyelash
extensions like you've like you've set
yourself up right like you've put effort
into Beauty tonight
but you know I
I work all the time and so I don't get
dressed up for that because I can't and
so it's when I want to go out I want to
look good or if I if I'm on camera or
whatever I want to look good that just
helps me in my own I don't dress for
anyone I dress for myself I love fashion
I love clothes so just because the way I
look doesn't does
prove anything well it's really
interesting about this conversation
we're having just put a quick pause on
this for everybody listening and the
panel what rich and I are saying is that
we're not even mad about this we are
saying that's female nature it's as if
it's like getting mad at water for being
wet or for the Sun for burning your skin
when you go outside and there's such a
fight for like we're not calling women
gold diggers we're like no that's that's
just it's it's acceptable I understand
that as a man if I stop doing what I
need to do stop chasing Excellence stop
taking care of myself let my [__] fall
apart why do I deserve or how have I
earned a woman's companionship and for
her to stay with me I mean the the men
that are crying about gold diggers are
the ones that think that they deserve
this unconditional love from a woman no
matter what they do and all we're
telling men is to you have the burden of
performance and it's up to you to earn
that every single day so it's it's
always interesting to me because people
think rich and I come with these
conversations like we're you know we
hate women but we're saying No this is
female nature and guess what that's okay
we're also trying to show you a side
that you
it's like the whole you don't know what
you don't know sort of thing like stuff
in your blind spot like you only see so
much in life and where you're going what
you do and the choices and all that sort
of stuff but
once you figure out the assessment
process with human beings by looking at
their results in life and how they hold
themselves out you can then determine
the choices that they make and what
their belief system looks like right
like it's a sequence of events that sort
of like goes down to the inner core of
the human being right so when I'm when
I'm posing a question or making a
statement like what do you think of the
notion that women are Beauty objects and
then it causes pain and hurt with you I
I get curious like genuinely curious
like okay well why you know why is that
statement like why do you call men and
women on a long-term basis if they're
going to get into marriage a team like
how does that work like how does that
model work in a long-term relationship
and I'm looking to sort of explore those
questions with you Kelly
I mean just yeah I've been I've been
called an object before and like it's
it's not it's not a compliment it's not
necessarily maybe not a dig but
like it didn't I didn't cry about it
what would you like to be recognized for
if it's not Beauty
I mean my my intelligence I'm funny as
hell like I I've been called I I know
I'm a good person because my dad raised
me for the most part but like I hear my
friends or even just strangers I mean
people I meet friends at Walgreens CVS
and they're like you're such a nice
person I'm like thank you like
thank you and like I don't take that to
the head I don't think I'm a Tim but
it's just like it's
it's not just Beauty we're gonna have so
much to offer yeah I don't think that
we're distilling it down to just Beauty
but but that's the primary reason why
like if you're out there dating and you
know your object is you know to find a
relationship that might lead to
something or marriage or children or any
of those things
you must understand that men are looking
at you first and foremost for your
beauty though right
I mean that's the first impression yeah
like like the did you go to college or
like University or anything yeah
did you have a you know like a degree
um I do not I'm not finished yet okay so
like most people when they get a degree
they'll put it on the wall it's got
little letters after the name it's got
mahogany they you know they're very
proud of it sort of thing but
intelligence or comedy or you know
accomplishments and work are not like
there's no guys like if moth and I are
sitting down having a drink and a
beautiful woman walk by he wouldn't lean
over and Whisper at me and go oh yeah
look at the degree on her or I bet she's
really funny right the the the
compliment generally goes and you know
what you're wearing and and how you look
right so
I guess what I'm asking you here is
impression though you can't help that
like should I wear a hoodie it covers my
face no that's not what I'm saying but I
know I know it's like how men are
success objects to women right I don't I
don't get hurt when when a woman says
well I want a sex I want a successful
guy he like women have a long laundry
list of Demands generally speaking when
it comes to men especially for long-term
relationships or if they're gonna be
like have a family and kids and all that
sort of stuff he's got to be tall he's
got to be funny he's got to be competent
he's got to be unselfish he's got to be
humble he's got to be Alpha he's got to
be amazing in the bedroom he's got to be
able to like all these things exactly
but it's but it's predominantly just
distilled down to men must be a success
object and I think that's completely
okay and men should surrender to the
notion that that's how women typically
look at men so I'm curious from the
women on the panel now is
does does the notion of me saying that
men are success objects is that
offensive is that something that you
don't co-sign is that something that
bothers you or do you like that notion
no I mean I don't even I don't think the
beauty object thing is bad either or the
success object because it's just it just
is what it is like we are women we are
beautiful so like why not use it like
this is how it is in society this is how
we're viewed like you said has a power
use it to empower yourself and it
doesn't mean that you're an object it
just means okay this is the role that
we've been given as humans as women yeah
you can substitute object for role yeah
so like you can just like use it like we
can use keyword is beauty versus success
basically is what I'm saying yeah we can
use our Beauty to gain success in
whatever way we want and like be our
best selves and be our healthiest selves
and men can use their role of being
successful to get wherever they want to
be in life so I think that's just how it
is to be a man and a woman we're just
different in that way like I mean the
same question you sound with but I find
it interesting that when when women are
offered an opportunity to
um be on the cover of a magazine you
know for example or to Showcase
something the first thing that they do
is they don't write like stand-up comedy
lines they they put on something nice
that exposes skin and they sell stuff
right like because they're Beauty
objects like Gia like you've got a large
following and you basically built that
large following off modeling and fitness
modeling and all that sort of stuff
right
um
that's that's how that's how men turned
you that's how culture and Society sort
of turns to you as they look to you for
that sort of stuff and you respond in
kind by providing you know uh marketing
opportunities to companies that have uh
supplements nutritional products
exercise lines all that sort of stuff
right like does that make sense
it as men the reason why they do notice
Beauty and they see a beautiful woman is
because that is who is going to have
their kids like they're thinking
biologically you know instinctively
they're seeing you as okay what type of
child would I have right so if he sees
you as a beauty object that's not a
negative thing you have to kind of like
change your perspective on his View and
then him being a success you know we
want as women somebody
if you look you know hundreds of years
ago a man who was status he was a
warrior right he had he could protect
you he could look over you so I think
it's just perspective it's how we need
to start looking at things you know you
disagreed with them but then now you
just backed it up like you agree with
both sides
I'm sorry what so like when they asked
initially if like you agree with you
know the statements of women and men and
you disagreed with them and then you
basically just agreed with them just now
yes I'm agreeing with them I'm saying
that you shouldn't see if somebody sees
you as a beauty object you have to
understand the male perspective it's not
a negative thing no I understand I I
yeah
so what's your what's your take on that
notion with men being success objects
and women being Beauty objects because
that's it yeah I
I could biological inclination towards
looking at women they used to that's why
if you look back at like statues and
things like that women had the big
curvier hips because they're more
mother-bearing hips and things of that
nature those are the things that are
idealized for men and it's literally
just a biological reaction nine times
out of ten
um and and I don't think I don't take it
as an insult and I I think it's a big
challenge for females especially that
you know and something that I've had to
work on is understanding that being view
viewed as a beauty object or I think the
issue that maybe Kelly and other people
and maybe instinctually I even had with
you originally and with some of your
perspectives was that it often minimizes
the capabilities and the attributes of
women in that
if you summarize it in such a quick
sound bite you're minimizing all the
attributes and contributions of a female
partner in your life to one internally
Locust thing so there's internal locus
and external locus of what the focus is
and then we can go and I remember you
pivoting never mind going back
um so like even when you were talking
about
you know the contributions to your you
in your relationship if you're just
saying I only care about the beauty
aspect the external so then if you're
procreating with somebody you have a kid
with somebody if you have a kid with
somebody and you only care about the
beauty she is the most like chef's kiss
beautiful woman in the world but then
you don't expect anything else from her
you don't expect her character her
Integrity her drop into your child as
well or she purely serving the role of
the visual
what that means
go ahead rich but I mean you have to be
clear so you're asking them as a
question yeah
well first and foremost I think Beauty
cues are what men are evolutionary
predisposed to like right like there's
symmetry there's uh hip to waist ratio
there's breast size and fullness uh lip
fullness like these are all attraction
cues that
um we as a function of evolution would
be drawn to
um the notion of is she funny is she
um you know she virtuous is she a good
person does she have a good family these
are all things that are like more recent
right
um we would and still to this day I mean
men and women make these mate choices
based on fundamental hardwiring in our
DNA
um you know to say that hypergamy is
evil as an example some some guys get
really pissed off and like well women
aren't choosing me they're choosing the
tall broad shoulder Rich successful guy
with the lambo over there with a nice
you know watch on his wrist that sucks
that program he blows I can't beat this
and they boom like you know they get all
upset
um that's just a feature of women's
mates like if they didn't choose a guy
that's competent That Could Make It Rain
that has resources
um that has influence that is a leader
then it could it could spell death for
her and her children not today so much
but you know 10 20 000 years ago the
potential existed but we haven't changed
that much you know like we're still just
monkeys you know we just figured out how
to make roads and create stream yard
links and podcasts and all this sort of
stuff with microphones like we're still
essentially primates so there's certain
things that I encourage people when I
have these conversations to like well
that hurts or that feels wrong or why is
it that way and it's like I want to
challenge those Notions with these
podcasts and having these conversations
because I think it leads to interesting
conversations Enlightenment discussion
and all of those things so back to your
point of you know like you know
selecting women yeah first and foremost
I'm looking at her beauty 100 then as
time goes on
um and you spend more time whether like
you look at other qualities and traits
like does she have culinary skills does
this woman know how to cook right
because if I'm going to have children
with her is she going to be able to feed
them is she going to be able to feed me
while I'm out you know hunting and
Gathering or whatever sort of thing like
this is how we're predisposed to sort of
think so do those things matter sure
they matter but they don't matter as
much of the Optics of beauty and
attraction from the get-go because at
the end of the day you know there's
people like oh well you know I'm sure
she's got a really nice personality
quality or like you can learn to love
her sort of thing like that but you
can't bang a nice personality right what
somebody looks like first and foremost
is what draws you and it's the same
thing with women you know to men right
like there's women that try to get
involved with guys that might have a
nice personality or they dismiss certain
prerequisites that they might have and
then that just leads to disappointment
and breakups later on down the road
which don't need to happen if you know
if you first and foremost set these uh
minimum requirements to be set I'm not
talking about the long laundry list of
the 621 things that most modern women
have today talk about fundamental Basics
right like no I think I think the area
of opportunity I'm
experiencing from listening to
um you know your perspectives and and
how you're educating the people that
follow you are that you know you
perceive yourself as a high value man
you call yourself a high value man you
call yourself an alpha I've never called
myself a high value man you don't use
those words one podcast I listen to
there's a podcast that I literally
whatever doesn't matter whatever you
talk about those values for culture and
Society to decide what I am how how it
is that they see me I don't tell them
how to see me I love that I can
appreciate that
um I I would be curious come back to
yourself Kelly I'd be curious of what
because I think my core issue that I'm
having and I'm blocking here is that I
feel like you're you're minimizing the
the importance of both roles I'm not I
believe man has had a household I
Believe In traditional masculine
feminine I am full believing of all that
and and something that I I'm I just feel
like you're minimizing the female
contribution and we can talk about for
sure for family Dynamics or just in
relationship in life I don't care but
what do you mean by minimizing the
female contribution what do you mean if
you I think sometimes it
how it's summarizing is that
beautiful you have to look you have to
be in an asset on their arm you have to
be that and I'm not disagreeing with
your innate biological reaction to you
wanting to find someone who is good to
procreate with because again I believe
in that as well but you're minimizing to
that's
the stopping point and then you're like
oh well maybe then yeah you can think
about their culinary skills but women
are so much beyond the scope of
yeah can you [__] me and then can I cook
you make you a sandwich I think it's so
much beyond that scope in your I feel
like you keep pigeonholing women into
that scope I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out